hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm danielle
we're gonna check out the trailer for
barely lethal its has sexual material
team drinking I love watching teens get
drunk language drug references and some
action and violence that then it's pg-13
that doesn't sound like a be pg-13
that's not that sounds very r-rated I
think anything with a teen drinking
should be r-rated we got a censor our
community action violence I know you
know if teens are only sometimes killing
themselves not entertaining more
murderers amongst teens I've said that
before yeah a real life I never knew my
parents the only thing I ever knew was
Prescott especially school for orphans
back of a lot of grandmas know that had
some unique ideas about education
meet Victoria Knox American arms dealer
can you age of 83 and bring her here
don't touch me talk seen your papers I'm
Savannah Commission High School was a
gun you take it this is your first
assembly this awesome not usually
foreign exchange student sounds like you
could not noticing you're into cash huh
- loves the spirit thanks Gus oh my host
/ research suggests that they're offered
loners
hold the mascot rats it's tradition
83 how did you find YouTube now it's
escaped and she left a really nice death
threat when that finds out where you are
she would destroy you
Wow all the way up to the third fire she
better bring finger bring it before
10:30 I've got a curfew psycho [ __ ]
give us some time
no crime why are you crying maybe she
watched the notebook one too many times
some lessons is a very volatile time for
a young woman he's so kids me
that looks so horrible that looks like I
can't believe I even just got through
that previous first of all why is he Sam
eulogizing running another school I I
don't quite get what any of them are
really doing I don't even know what I
can't even tell you what I just watched
it's like four different movies first
it's like I guess like a family
action-adventure of spies and then like
oh we're in Mean Girls now it's about
yeah that's that was the shitty part cuz
a minute of it was kind of cool was like
okay I could be on board for this Sam
Jackson cheesy action comedy and then
when it went to high school live the
[ __ ] music and do teens still listen
to that kind of music like with the
[ __ ] like Punk kind of sounding and
like they go to high school with some
guy with long hair cut yeah change yeah
like you make those jokes when you're in
your mid-20s like I do
vaginas a funny word though so many ways
you could say it bad you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] beef curtains beef curtains I
haven't heard that one in a while the
beef garden seat curtains this is how
she promotes her sexual image right here
right now you feel comfortable with this
that looks like it's gonna I mean why
Sam Hill I mean look it looks like pure
crap it looks like exactly everything
wrong with a movie and it's straight too
deep it looks like straight-to-dvd
made it looks like these guys didn't
give a [ __ ] and they were like how can
we get every audience market out there
let's throw in every kind of film in one
book yeah sex symbol I mean he is pretty
hot she's really hot
want to do things ah my girlfriend's in
the other room and we have jealousy
issues so you know if I start saying
she's hot then you know then she's gonna
say someone else is hot yeah yeah yeah
is fantastic really sexy Jessica Alba I
know a guy named Greg Alba oh he is one
of the sexiest [ __ ] I heard
yeah oh my he's a legend this Greg album
oh gosh big legend yeah that's what they
say right it's men and women animals and
animals yeah well how do the dolphin say
it Danielle how do they say that could
be like several different enemy yeah at
first I was like I don't like this
because now they just change it to a
boring teen world you got Samuel Jackson
and you got the girl I think her name's
Hailee Steinfeld she's the one in True
Grit
she's a great actress and you take two
really good actors you put them in crap
and then they tried meshing the worlds
together and the end of this trailer
yeah like like this is all gonna come to
it yeah and like this just doesn't make
sense my life really really terrible you
know movies good when it's brought to
you by DIRECTV yeah I hope I get
sponsorship from them one day anyway I
have a rating system now for the
trailers it goes definitely going to see
it in the theaters okay
other variations of that waiting for it
on DVD other variations of that not even
bother with it this one is the first
trailer where I finally get to say I'm
not even gonna bother with it
screen shot I'm Danielle
look so bad well you would die if you
saw this preview yeah lose all hope in
humanity I lost a testicle I lost like
that was a long preview - that was a
long one
it showed you the whole movie [ __ ] I
liked how we saw a trailer in the whole
movie and we're like the whole movie
sucks if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and danielle has a personal life that I
won't tell you about and you can follow
me on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where I am constantly posting photos of
my girlfriend and I doing kinky stuff
it's good [ __ ] it's really good [ __ ]
sometimes [ __ ] is involved not on my
side she's into disgusting things know
the popsicle he doesn't stop with the
popsicle popsicle the poop popsicles are
the worst but she managed to have a
stick come on them - which is like
amazing though like it's perfect you
know what this was a funny joke until I
really started imagining this happening